[Music]
foreign
time then for the Press preview it's our
first look at the front pages of
Monday's papers and tonight we'll see
what's making the headlines with the
spectators economics editor Kate Andrews
who's joined by the columnist and
broadcaster Steve Richard it's a very
good evening to both of you and now as
you can imagine the papers have all had
to change their front pages uh extremely
quickly I think we can bring you the
front page of the Guardian uh at least
uh let's show you the front of the
Guardian have we got that
it's coming
yeah a bit of a nightmare for newspaper
editors isn't it when news breaks uh
just after nine o'clock on a Sunday but
there you are the front of the Guardian
not the right time Johnson out of race
to lead the Tories the guardian quoting
from Boris Johnson's statement of an
hour and a half or so ago well let's get
the thoughts of our paper reviewers this
evening Steve and Kate great to see you
and what an evening it has been uh Kate
let's come to you first were you
surprised by this news
well I suppose I'm surprised by
everything these days I'm surprised
we're having another toy leadership
contest you know it all adds up uh but I
think uh there's a lot to break down in
the statement that Boris Johnson put out
this evening uh number one he seemed uh
extremely confident not only in his
prospects that he could win and be the
Prime Minister again next week but that
he could actually lead the Tories to
another general election Victory he also
insisted that he did have the number of
nominations to get himself onto that
ballot but decided that it was his
choice not to run because he didn't
think it was the right time and he
didn't think he could bring uh the
conservative MPS together the word he
used was Unity at this time we will
never know if Boris Johnson had enough
MPS to get onto the ballot there was a
lot of speculation about that today
there were a lot of briefings most
Anonymous suggesting that Boris Johnson
was having more frustration getting to
that figure but Boris and his backers
insisted that they were going to have it
uh I imagine that this is a very
difficult moment for the Prime Minister
because we all know he didn't want to
leave Downing Street just weeks ago that
he felt ousted that he still feels like
that mandate is his but I think it was
becoming very clear that Boris just
could not command the support of his MPS
anymore so even if he could command the
support of Grassroots members and get
himself back into the job the situation
would fundamentally be untenable and
rather than putting himself on the
ballot and going through that process or
perhaps experiencing a great humiliation
by not getting on the ballot at all he
decided to release a statement tonight
and try to claim some control over the
situation to say that it was his
decision not anybody else's uh yes the
front of the Metro uh their headline
Boris has bottled it xpm claims 102
nominations then quits I mean that is
the big question isn't it if he if he
had the number of MPS and of course
we'll never actually know because only
sir gray and Brady will know for sure
whether he reached that 102. if he says
that he has the backing of the Tory
party members and we know that many of
them do support still Boris Johnson uh
he could have gone for it but he is
saying that he's putting his personal
Ambitions to one side for the sake of
the party do you believe that
that makes me laugh that last bit I
think we've seen a manifestation of
personal ambition in the most
unrestrained and Preposterous way from
him over recent days here's someone who
couldn't form a government in July who
um rationalized his moment to come once
again a few weeks uh later and he's sort
of been a disruptive force in this kind
of mad mini leadership contest that's
going on so I don't believe that I'm not
sure whether he was a hundred percent
sure he had reached this hundred plus uh
threshold but the statement is very
interesting and disingenuous he said oh
I tried to bring us all together in
conversations with Penny mordant and
Richie sunac but they it didn't come off
what he really means is he asked them to
back him to be prime minister and they
would all form a team he wasn't offering
to be Northern Ireland secretary for
Rishi sunak and then at the end he says
I've got a lot more to offer but not now
now that translates as I still want to
be prime minister and that's what I've
got to offer it didn't work for me today
so I think he's got I think to be honest
uh this might hurt him more uh than when
he was booted out in July because I
think he rationalized there and it was
soon act and a couple of others
conspiring against it but now he's come
up against a harsh reality the MPS
Beyond his devotees were not flocking to
him as he rushed back from his holiday
uh to save his party in his country as
he probably saw it yeah front page of
the son Kate sunac set to be next MP
Bojo it's a no Boris steps aside to
avoid chaos
um you've touched on this already but
what do you think is going to happen
tomorrow do you think it will be a sunac
coronation uh is that a given now
um because the big question I suppose is
is where does that support for Boris
Johnson go because if a lot of it went
to Penny Morton she could feasibly cross
the line
um it's really difficult to know and
anything is feasible at this point Boris
Johnson has about 60 publicly declared
backers but remember there are dozens of
MPS who have not come out and said here
they're supporting at all yet so there
is still all to play for
um the first obvious question is if
Penny Morton can get to the 100 MPS she
needs because if she can't then it's a
done deal for issue CNAC but let's say
she were just to scrape 100 MPS maybe
say got 105. at that point what would
the pressure from the Tory party be put
upon Penny Morton to say are you really
going to take us through this week are
you really going to send that ballot to
the members she may well decide she's
going to but at that point you would
expect probably some kind of
conversation to take place between Rishi
sunak and Petty Morton
um and I think a very good point was
made there that Boris Johnson was never
really trying to bring the three of them
together he was suggesting that they
could get in line behind him and of
course Boris Johnson is very used to
that he got used to in his Premiership
having MPS support him in very difficult
usually quite personal situations in
which the cabinet had to come out and
defend the prime minister's actions
scandal after Scandal related to
partygate in particular and I think it
was probably quite shocked abortionalism
at this time round Penny mordant and
Richie zunak did not get behind him but
again if you look at the numbers why
would you necessarily Penny Morton
thinks I've got just as good a shot as
you do Boris and rishi's sitting there
with double the number of MPS publicly
backing him than Boris has
um Jeremy Hunt just in the past few
minutes has come out and support Rishi
sunak of course the chancellor now and
notably was more or less promised by
Penny Morden that that he would remain
Chancellor she got the nomination sorry
she got the top job so the fact that
he's actually come out to back where
she's Sue Knack is very good news for
the former Chancellor tonight
um but no of course there's still all to
play for and if Penny Morton does get
those 100 MPS she may well decide she
wants there to be a membership vote and
let's remember that might not be the
worst news urishi sunak again a lot of
people just want there to be a new prime
minister that so that he or she can get
on with the job but rishi's biggest
problem at the moment is that he was
rejected by the membership albeit by a
closer March and then people thought it
would be just weeks ago and it might not
be the worst thing in the world if he
was back on the ballot and the members
actually voted him and then he would
have that clear mandate from the
Grassroots which at the moment if if he
if he's the only one to get 100 plus MPS
he wouldn't be able to say with
confidence yeah um you mentioned that
article in the telegraph written by
Jeremy Hunter we've just managed to pull
it up with Rishi seen that we have
someone who in our best Traditions will
turn the page on what went wrong take
decisions in the National interest and
rebuild the extraordinary potential of
our economy voters of all parties know
this perfectly well they're hoping and
praying We Choose Wisely we must not let
them down so the chancellor backing
Rishi sunak but he is a divisive figure
isn't he Steve
foreign
well yes I mean in the sense that some
of Boris Johnson's facts kind of blame
him for uh what happened to Boris
Johnson in July but as I say that was
always irrational and wrong and maybe
Boris Johnson himself will come to
realize that in the light of this
weekend's events he's divisive in a
different way I mean he is a
self-declared fiscal conservative I've
read in recent days that if they elect
uh sunat rather than Johnson it will be
a move to the center ground to the left
of the Tory party he is a self-declared
kind of thatcherite so
um that's not the case economically in
his haphazard way Johnson was to the
left of Rishi sumac so it could be
divisive in the sense that the hunt uh
sunac axis will be very uh fiscally
conservative uh kind of try and adopt
that culture of balancing the books in a
sort of George Osborne way and that was
involved some very tough decisions but
I've never understood why the so-called
right of the party sort of said oh
sooner he's appalling he's a socialist I
mean it was a part of the craziness of
this period that he was framed in such a
way yeah you make an interesting point
then if we bring in the I see that
favorite for number 10 after Tori MP's
Force Johnson to quit they mentioned
Kate uh that Boris Johnson lost support
of swella bravaman also Steve Baker
today who who came out to support Richie
sunac
I think this will have been part of the
calculation for Boris Johnson to pull
his name tonight because it was very
clear that the so-called right of the
party was splitting it was not going to
back Boris Johnson and once while a
Braverman
um Steve Baker and then others who
wouldn't have had a vote but are very
influential figures like David Frost
were coming out for Rishi sunak there
was a real sense that something was
changing it's also interesting to note
the final comments in Boris Johnson
statement tonight where he says I have a
lot to give but this isn't the moment
um it reminded me of the column that um
heavyweight conservative columnist
Charles Moore wrote over the weekend for
the telegraph in which he basically said
Boris I think you're fantastic but this
is not your moment this is an economic
crisis and we need the economic Sky the
Rishi sunat character to come in and fix
it and I I you know I thought it was
interesting that that language was
repeating itself and perhaps that was
part of the message that was relayed to
the former prime minister over the
weekend which is you know we a lot of
his supporters will always
um like him and and and see the good
that they think he did for the country
but this is simply not the moment and
perhaps that messaging cut through
um and then just lastly I think it is
such an important Point that's been made
about the so-called left and right of
the conservative party it was a baffling
definition over the summer because all
of a sudden being the one to want to
balance the books became to the left of
the party um and I think the reason
where she's seen that they tried to
label him as left of the party was
because he had raised taxes but of
course we know that he was raising taxes
because he was so worried about
inflation and the state of the public
finances and losing Market confidence
which has become the reason that we're
having another leadership election I
thought that Jerry Hunt's comments when
he spoke last Monday were actually very
soon act-esque in style so I can't say
I'm terribly surprised that he has come
out for the former Chancellor tonight
yeah it's gonna be really interesting
isn't it seeing how the markets react to
to this news welcome back you're
watching uh part two the Press preview
Kate Andrews and Steve Richards still
with us front page of the times Steve
soon accept for number 10 is Johnson
quits race interestingly they quote
Nadeem zahawi here the cabinet office
Minister who of course endorsed Boris
Johnson this morning but tonight uh
tweeted given today's news it's clear
that we should turn to Rishi sunak um I
mean it just shows how how quickly
things change
it shows what to put it at its most for
light an unreliable narrator he is and
his tweet tonight on Twitter
um basically roughly translated is oh
sorry Richard I got all this a bit wrong
uh do give me a job in the cabinet you
know
um and politics can be a really Noble
vocation and it can be utterly
humiliating and I think he has with his
behavior actually in recent weeks really
humiliated himself but it's a sign that
the momentum I know it's a cliche but
momentum really does matter in these
very short contests is with sunak you
know that you've had Jeremy Hunt coming
out for him you've had him coming out
for him uh having declared for Boris
Johnson and there will probably be a bit
more of that in the coming hours
uh looking at the Daily Telegraph Kate
we know Jeremy Hunt uh has uh has
written for the telegraph supporting
Rishi sunap but there's also a piece
here by Camilla tomini um headline don't
be fooled into thinking the psycho drama
is over
well that she anything in that piece
because
this is a brilliant writer I'm sure it's
a very insightful one
um and it's not over uh you know Rishi
sunak is not yet declared the leader of
the conservative party or the Prime
Minister Penny Morton May well get over
the threshold she may get a hundred plus
MPS she may decide she wants that ballot
to go to the membership so that she can
have her chance so uh this contest is
not over but because it's short we're
going to know either tomorrow or on
Friday
um uh who the next prime minister will
be and the huge challenges ahead of them
um and uh you know the huge economic
crisis that we now find ourselves in the
desperation to get the markets back on
side this is the real Challenge and it's
interesting to look at the polling over
the past few days because there it is
very clear that Rishi sunak commands uh
more attention when it comes to the
economy that there's far more trust in
him than there has been in the other
candidates
um but you know this is at the moment a
battle between Tory MPS and then the
Tory Grassroots and they're going to be
looking at a whole host of things and so
the contest is certainly not over yet
yeah Camilla tomany um I think was
focusing on Boris Johnson she says in
this piece like all good headline acts
he decided to keep the audience waiting
in the sort of will he won't he guessing
game that's come to characterize his
entire uh political career you can read
more about that in the telegraph here's
a paper we don't feature very often
Steve City am it's the the business
paper for London that's uh that's handed
out uh in the morning Boris not this
time their headline a picture of Boris
Johnson there with his head in his hands
and and we're focusing on this really
because it shows that all papers have
had to do this last minute change and it
is uh fascinating how the front page can
change and sometimes has to change very
quickly
it's really interesting as well in this
kind of New Media era
um I mean a few years ago this would
have been a nightmare for newspapers who
would have to you know actually a lot of
their physical copies would not have
been able to be updated in time but now
in a way that they're closer with these
Digital Editions I assume have you got
digital front pages I don't know whether
it's the physical newspaper or digital
but assuming it's digital they can move
much more quickly these days I mean it's
almost like uh rolling news not as fast
as as you obviously because you can get
it out immediately to viewers but they
can move so much more quickly than in
that pre uh digital era where they would
you know the first editions would have
gone long ago and people would have been
buying the physical newspapers with
speculation about you know whether
Johnson was gonna win or not so that's I
mean the good thing for newspapers
they're struggling in many specs is this
kind of digital Dimension that's right
thank you both very much